Can I ask your thoughts on Brexit?
Yes,
you can have my thoughts on brexit and
the other day I was doing a lecture on
the on the stories in genesis and one of
the stories that I analyze briefly,
and this will be posted very soon is the
story of the Tower of Babel and I've
been very curious about that story.
It comes after Noah's flood myth in
genesis.
What happens is that human beings get
together and they decide to build a
massive building and the human beings
that are building that building all
speak in one voice and they have this
grand vision which you might regard as a
utopian vision,
which is what I think it is,
that they can build a building so high
that within it everyone will speak the
same language and it will reach all the
way to have it,
and so you could see it in some sense as
an attempt to usurp the transcendent.
I kind of read it as an an early
precursor of the story that Milton told
and paradise lost.
Where Satan,
who's God's highest heavenly angel and
perhaps and who's Lucifer?
The brightest light in the psychic
hierarchy you might say,
and the spirit of untrammeled
rationality decides that he can wage war
in heaven and overcome God,
overcome the ultimate in the
transcendent value,
and I read that as a cautionary tale
about the pride that goes along with
intellectual presupposition in the same
pride that produced the totalitarian
states of the 20th century.
What happens with the Tower of Babel is
that human beings start to build this,
a unitary homogenous structure who's
pinnacle will reach into God's heavenly
domain,
perhaps thereby taking the place of the
transcendent.
God gets wind of that and goes to earth
and takes the people or or transforms
the people who are,
who are building them.